[Musique]
la nouvelle série qui réveille la
politique française
l'Assemblée nationale profondément
chamboulée par les élections
législatives
captivent les regards et les députés
font le spectacle
vous êtes des incapables vous êtes des
hypocrites et vous êtes des menteurs 50
ans après vos cravates ne cacheront
jamais votre flamme oui nous avons le
droit de débattre et de ne pas nous
faire insulter c'est votre faute
aujourd'hui c'est les agriculteurs se
suicident
si maintenant
on ne vous entend jamais parfois endormi
sous la dernière mandature l'assemblée
s'est réveillé
que ce soit à ce point-là une marmite
bouillonnante
parfois dans l'excès parce que c'est
c'est un sentiment humain parfaitement
compréhensible le spectacle le
parlementaire
et désormais permanent et déborde sur
tous les écrans bonjour à toutes et à
tous cette petite vidéo pour vous
présenter mon activité Assemblée
nationale
de l'obstruction aucune vision aucune
anticipation pas une journée sans qu'une
oeuvre d'art ne soit badigeonnée de je
ne sais quelle soupe aux légumes les
Clash TikTok aujourd'hui on remplacé les
duels à l'épée ce qui prévaut c'est
l'affrontement toujours partout et
surtout les sujets
l'Assemblée nationale revenu au cœur du
jeu démocratique peut-elle réconcilier
les Français avec la politique c'est
tout l'enjeu pour les députés qui font
aujourd'hui du débat parlementaire un
spectacle permanent
et vous êtes des menteurs
[Musique]
personnages principal de notre première
épisode l'émission
merci Madame avec ces sièges rouges et
ses dorures il est depuis la Révolution
le Grand Théâtre du jeu politique
français
[Musique]
l'hémicycle en principe historiquement
c'est le cœur de la démocratie française
c'est une arène c'est un forum qui
reprend d'ailleurs quelque part les
codes de ce qui était la démocratie à
Athènes et à Rome il faut voir que
l'hémicycle c'est le premier endroit où
on va prévoir des tribunes
historiquement c'est le premier endroit
également dont on va faire un compte
rendu qui va être diffusé à l'ensemble
de la population et c'est là réellement
que va se synthétiser la mise en scène
de cette vie politique donc on a un
aspect théâtral cet aspect théâtral il
est assumé mais il a tout son rôle dans
la représentation
alors
ça crée du cœur
parmi nous silence pour la France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on connaît la stratégie de l'extrême
droite qui agit comme la chauve-souris
de la fable dans le parti des oiseaux
elle montre ses ailes dans le parti des
fachos elle montre son poil et elle
atteint un rat
je pense que vous comportez comme des
hadistes et vous risquez de dégrader le
Mobilier national car
s'il vous plaît
avec 88 députés rassemblement national
74 pour la France insoumise et une
majorité relative pour le gouvernement
je sortais en silence les rapports de
force sont changés sur les bancs
et les séances s'en ressentent
de cinq minutes bon on fait une
suspension de séance de 5 minutes tu vas
la faire mais
non c'est pas possible
et tu
n'avais pas non la séance est suspendue
pour 5 minutes pas possible je ne
m'étais pas imaginer que ça soit à ce
point-là une marmite bouillonnante le
plus souvent
et même à la limite du débordement sur
certains débats il y a des éclats de
voix c'est le ton monte énormément il y
a des gestes des gens qui se lèvent en
fait il y a quelque chose de très
physique même dans cette hémicycle c'est
représentatif de ce qu'est tout
simplement la vie et la culture
française et même la civilisation de la
petite en général nous nous sommes une
civilisation où on exprime l'entièreté
du panel des sentiments il y a une part
de vérité de parfois dans l'excès parce
que c'est c'est un sentiment humain
parfaitement compréhensible parfaitement
normal et vouloir aseptiser le Parlement
au nom de pseudo responsabilité ou pour
avoir l'air sérieux il y a rien de
sérieux dans la négation de la nature
humaine
nouvelle vision vous donnez
ez pour exister dans ce chaudron nous
sommes
ici la tentation est grande de
théâtralisée toujours plus les
interventions
par exemple en joignant le geste à la
parole c'est ce qu'a fait la députée
écologiste Sandrine Rousseau nous sommes
alors en pleine affaire Adrien katnas
c'est un geste des féministes des années
70 un geste qui représente le vagin pour
moi il était très important de le poser
comme un symbole envoyé aux femmes à
toutes les femmes qui toujours se sont
battues pour leurs droits leur dire je
suis là pour vous mais c'était pour
réveiller les consciences et pour
choquer oui s'affrontalement je j'avais
décidé de choquer certains groupes ont
fait de la provocation leur marque de
fabrique
c'est inscrit dans leur stratégie
politique tout ça est pensé tout ça est
organisé lorsque vous voulez politiser
l'opinion lorsque vous voulez faire
passer un message soit vous écrivez des
livres à rallonge que pas grand monde ne
va lire soit vous décidez de donner une
portée en faisant de la communication on
sait qu'en communication un message qui
est pertinent c'est 90 secondes et donc
en 90 secondes une minute trente vous
devez être
offensif pour qu'on vous retienne ce
n'est plus Jupiter c'est le parrain
[Applaudissements]
vous préférez manger des pépitos que de
voter sur le projet de loi de finances
j'espère que le gâteau était bon de
toute façon quoi qu'on propose vous
écoutez pas et vous racontez n'importe
quoi la vérité c'est que tout le monde
voit que vous le cherchez que le chaos
pour
tant c'est vous alors je vous en prie un
peu de modestie croyez-moi ça pourrait
bien vous allez au thym les indignations
grandiloquantes les clashs les petites
phrases interroge parfois sur le rôle du
Parlement les historiquement ils font
partie de son ADN les débats
d'aujourd'hui n'ont rien d'exceptionnel
il y a eu des périodes où on s'est battu
dans l'hémicycle et où les insultes les
coûts échanger volley bas je pense aux
années
90 au moment de l'affaire Dreyfus moment
de la séparation des Églises et de
l'État je pense aux années 30 ou les
députés insultaient Léon Blum donc ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui finalement se
situe un peu dans une tradition c'est
quelque chose qui n'a rien
d'exceptionnel
ce qui a changé c'est la résonance que
prend aujourd'hui ce spectacle épisode 2
comment et pourquoi il s'invite en
permanence sur tous vos écrans
le député RN Julien audoul entre deux
séances
m se rendre dans le jardin de
l'assemblée
il vient ici ce n'est pas seulement pour
admirer les massifs fleuris on va
peut-être s'incliner
dans ce sens là comme ça on voit les
on voit l'entrée des quatre colonnes
c'est surtout pour se faire filmer dans
un cadre esthétique
par son collaborateur chers amis cette
petite vidéo pour vous présenter mon
activité l'Assemblée nationale alors les
débats ne sont pas toujours
effectivement apaisés ce jour-là Julien
Audoux a choisi sa cible les députés de
gauche dont il veut dénoncer le
comportement à l'assemblée de
l'opposition comme ceux de la nupes ceux
de la nuit Pesse qui sont toujours
promptes à nous sauter dessus sur un
certain nombre d'interventions qui sont
quelquefois de très mauvaise foi il faut
bien le dire pour pour les députés ces
vidéos postées sur les réseaux sociaux
permettent de prolonger encore les
débats parlementaires on peut
interpeller on peut clasher on peut
mettre en difficulté quelquefois soit
certaines positions des adversaires soit
revenir sur des déclarations ou des
interventions qui ont pu être faites
dans l'hémicycle donc oui effectivement
c'est une manière de continuer le débat
on peut dire que les Clash Tik Tok
aujourd'hui on remplacé les duels à
l'épée c'est à dire qu'on va prolonger
sur les écrans ce qui à l'époque à la
fin du 19e siècle par exemple ces
produits sur le chant clos en se battant
au pistolet à l'épée et quelquefois en
se blessant grièvement
à 37 ans Julien oudoux intervient sur
tous les grands réseaux sociaux
certains de ces messages peuvent
dépasser le million de vues une force de
frappe qu'il ne se prive pas d'utiliser
en variant les ambiances les cadres et
les supports
aujourd'hui les Verts ont une politique
ont une idéologie qui s'apparente aux
fascisme c'est-à-dire ce député est loin
d'être un cas isolé
[Musique]
de la cour d'honneur à la salle des
quatre colonnes
l'assemblée et capturé sous toutes ses
coutures par les smartphones des députés
les mises en scène inspirées de la
téléréalité de la pub ou des
influenceurs web
alimentent jour et nuit le feuilleton
parlementaire
à cheval j'avoue que je suis concentré
mais pas très sinon concentré pour faire
un bon discours que ce soit fort et
qu'on a déjà porté mon soutien au
gouvernement allez je pars au travail
madame vraiment
moi j'ai luçonne parce que on vient
d'avoir la première ministre dans
l'hémicycle qui nous a remis en 49-3 sur
le projet de bâtiment de la sécurité
sociale et donc tout ça tout notre
travail tout ce qu'on a fait tout ce
qu'on défend pour rien non mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça la France
insoumise décide de retirer sa
proposition de loi qui vise à réintégrer
les soignants non vaccinés la vidéo
c'est ce qui permet d'avoir un accès
direct au plus grand nombre donc pour
les députés c'est un exercice qui est
presque incontournable c'est le Palais
du Peuple ça appartient tout le monde
moi je trouve ça bien aussi que qui est
une familiarité qui puisse se créer par
les réseaux sociaux entre les Français
leur assemblée
et lui Renaissance Prisca theveno fait
partie de ses députés qui aiment
dégainer leur smartphone pour montrer
les coulisses des débats
en début de mandature elle publie cette
vidéo elle montre des députés nups et
rassemblement national qui se
réjouissent au même moment d'avoir mis
en échec la majorité présidentielle
l'extrait a dépassé les deux millions
200000 vues cette vidéo en réalité
illustre aussi ce que on dénoncé dès le
début de cette législature c'est qu'en
réalité il n'y a pas des extrêmes mais
il y a l'extrême l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite je pense qu'on a besoin
de voir et pour et pour pouvoir
retranscrire ce qui s'y passe et bien
oui il y a besoin de d'image de visuels
de son de temps en temps et ça permet de
mettre le citoyen au centre de
l'hémicycle
dans son bureau à l'Assemblée
le député Louis Boyard va encore plus
loin il possède tout le kit du parfait
influenceur web c'est très très simple
vous avez voilà de quoi mettre votre
téléphone une lumière pour adapter en
fonction de la lumière du jour ou de la
pièce vous posez votre téléphone et
ensuite vous voilà vous faites votre
vidéo et après l'idée c'est pas
uniquement de poster la vidéo telle
qu'elle est c'est ensuite de faire un
montage que ce soit quelque chose de
dynamique d'agréable à regarder il faut
que les cinq premières secondes de la
vidéo les gens ont compris de quoi
est-ce qu'on va parler et puis voilà en
fait on utilise exactement ce que
j'utilise n'importe quel autre créateur
sur Internet parce que nous sommes des
créateurs d'internet c'est juste que
nous on le fait pour porter des messages
politiques on se retrouve le 21 janvier
pour la manifestation contre la réforme
des retraites à l'appel des
organisations de la jeunesse j'y serai
présent et j'espère qu'on va s'y
retrouver à bientôt
c'est l'un des députés les plus actifs
sur les réseaux à 22 ans Louis Boyard
rend maîtrise parfaitement les codes
alimenter ses comptes fait pour lui
partie du travail de député au même
titre que siéger en séance ou en
commission
moi j'ai commencé à me politiser sur
Youtube en regardant des vidéos sur
Twitter en lisant des avis des analyses
des articles de presse qui se
retrouvaient entre mes mains parce que
j'étais sur ces réseaux sociaux là et en
fait bah je suis voilà je suis sur
internet je consomme du contenu sur
Youtube qui n'a rien à voir avec la
politique comme tout le monde et du coup
pour moi c'est assez facile de reprendre
les codes d'Internet parce que bah je
suis un enfant d'Internet madame la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
pourquoi l'action du gouvernement
est-elle aussi pauvre qu'un sandwich du
CROUS comme louis-bouillard deux jeunes
députés hyper connectés ont fait leur
apparition à l'Assemblée en 2022
il revendique un ton plus libre et
assume la confrontation permanente sur
tous les terrains on est entassés ça
c'est la faute de la droite régionale de
Valérie Pécresse non non non non la nups
ne veut pas régler vos projets vos
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat quitte à
heurter la sensibilité de certains
confrères
maximum de tiktokers qui cherchent le
buzz tout ça induit quand même un climat
politique particulier
ou finalement
l'apaisement n'est plus de mise
ce qui prévaut c'est l'affrontement
toujours partout et surtout les sujets
vous savez l'image du politique n'est
pas très reluisante aujourd'hui donc
est-ce que
le recours à ce type de communication
est nature à rendre les élus plus plus
proche des Français je n'en sais rien
aujourd'hui je me pose très clairement
la question du maintien de mon compte
twitter je reconnais le caractère
pratique mais le caractère pratique
s'inscrit dans un outil dont je
considère qu'il est en opposition avec
l'idéal démocratique qui que je porte il
y a un côté poubelle dans Twitter qui ne
sert pas le fonctionnement démocratique
il y a une forme d'hystérisation de
dramatisation de mise en scène de
scénographie du débat parlementaire donc
forcément tout ça conduit à modifier la
nature du discours parlementaire et
aller vers des formes de j'allais dire
de brutalisation de ce de ce débat qui
sont pas toujours très positifs parce
qu'elles sont pas toujours très bien
comprises et très vous accepté par une
majorité de Français
comment les Français justement
perçoivent-ils cette nouvelle Assemblée
si éruptive c'est la question de notre
dernière épisode
[Musique]
Louis Boyard est en route pour
l'université de Tours la France
insoumise y organise une rencontre avec
les étudiants un électorative et par le
jeune député
je crois que jamais dans l'histoire la
jeunesse n'a été aussi politisée parce
qu'elle n'a jamais été aussi informée
avec les réseaux sociaux et reçoit des
notifications sur toutes les actualités
et en plus elle est intéressée à la
politique mais c'est plus une défiance
vis-à-vis des institutions et vis-à-vis
du fait que oui des institutions sont
capables de changer leur vie et de
répondre à leurs problèmes c'est ça nous
le sujet sur lequel on va les convaincre
[Musique]
sur place il y a full deux amphithéâtres
pleins et une ambiance aussi chaude que
dans l'hémicycle une rumeur Bruce dans
les couloirs des étudiants d'extrême
droite ce serait infiltrés
j'ai entendu que des fachos étaient
entrés dans la salle donc je vous
propose un accueil assez dignes en
disant siamoto
[Applaudissements]
fasciste
c'est à moi tout dit fascistes
accompagné d'Andy kerbra député de
Loire-Atlantique Louis Boyard évoque sa
vision des débats à l'Assemblée
LR a gagné puisque maintenant on porte
des costards à l'Assemblée nationale
donc vous vous voyez ça fait 6 mois que
nous on se bat pour essayer d'augmenter
les salaires de donner de l'argent aux
étudiants de venir des vrais mesures
contre le réchauffement climatique eux
ils sont plus occupés à nous faire
porter des costards faites vos choix
vous-même la deuxième les étudiants
venus à cette rencontre sont plutôt de
gauche et intéressés par la politique
depuis les élections de juin ils disent
suivre de plus près les débats
parlementaires je trouve ça plus
d'animaux quand il y a des débats quand
ça discute
c'est vrai que l'éloquence c'est hyper
important on regarde des fois ensemble
des séances d'essence parlementaires
donc j'ai l'impression que il y a
souvent plus de l'intervention un peu
musclé on va dire si c'est que des
histoires de provocation pour
provocation je sais pas s'il va y avoir
vraiment un impact il y a pas de faire
avancer les choses mais je pense que
c'est quand même important qui de
l'opposition et on attend de vous que
vous aussi tout répondit à l'appel donc
mes chers camarades faites mieux
prenez le courage jeune vous avez
aujourd'hui une assemblée qui peut
sembler beaucoup plus intéressantes
entre guillemets que les assemblées
précédentes c'est un électorat assez
clivé en réalité vous avez une grande
partie qui ne vote pas qui est à
politique vous avez une partie qui va
être plutôt Nupe vous n'avez également
une partie non négligeable qui vote RN
donc des moments où ces électorats sont
mieux représentés et où l'assemblée leur
donne le sentiment et bien de parler à
eux et de parler de leurs problèmes et
bien tout bêtement vous avez un effet de
représentativité ressentie bien plus
grande
cet effet se retrouve-t-il dans les
circonscriptions qui ont élus des
députés rassemblement national
[Musique]
Julien Oudoul vient à la rencontre des
commerçants du marché de Joigny
dans l'Yonne vous suivez un peu ce qui
se passe à l'Assemblée nationale
honnêtement je trouve que c'est pas
super en tant qu'image parce que ça fait
un peu trop
c'est il y a beaucoup de cirque il y a
pas beaucoup de fonds pour autant
l'Assemblée nationale a été élue par les
Français et ça engendre ce genre de
confrontation
des fois
tout à fait on en a besoin aussi de
temps en temps
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu penses de l'ambiance à
l'Assemblée
on va dire dans l'ensemble c'est à dire
que c'est bien ce que tous les partis
sont vraiment représentés enfin
notamment le vôtre et chacun défend
ses idées et c'est ce qui manquait une
république quand tu es une majorité on
est un peu piégé on va dire on a
l'impression que voilà que les Français
n'ont pas vraiment la parole je pense
qu'il y avait besoin de rééquilibrage
que le les Français ne majoritaires ont
souffert de la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron de la brutalité du mépris et du
manque de représentativité il faut bien
le dire d'avoir le sentiment que ils
avaient voté et qu'ils avaient un
parlement introuvable avec une majorité
omnipotence donc le fait qu'il soit
représenté par des élus par des un
groupe politique important
ça les conforte ça leur dit oui mais il
faut forcément qu'on les qu'on les
défende
risque de d'être un peu caricatural mais
en réalité c'est bien ce que rendent les
enquêtes plus vous montez dans l'échelle
de revenus plus vous avez de chances de
voter Emmanuel Macron plus vous
descendez plus vous avez de chances de
voter Marine Le Pen donc on a un
électorat qui est un électorat qui
structurellement a été sous-reprété
parce que le rassemblement national pour
des raisons d'exclusion du système
d'alliance de front républicain etc
étaient structurellement sous représenté
donc il y a un premier motif si ce n'est
de satisfaction en tout cas de
considération vis-à-vis de cette
nouvelle assemblée
la perception des débats parlementaires
n'est pas la même à Chaville cette
banlieue parisienne plutôt aisée est
très favorable à Emmanuel Macron ici le
président a dépassé les 80% au second
tour de la présidentielle
c'est la circonscription de Prisca TV
les week-ends
bientôt si ça vous intéresse bonne
journée comment ça va
bah ouais on vient on peut prendre la
température parce qu'on a chaud dans
l'hémicycle donc on vient prendre la
température sur le terrain comment vous
sentez que ça va là dans l'hémicycle les
gens ont plus de façon un petit peu
découragée sur la politique oui et ça
participe pas là le bruit complètement
une période un peu chaude un peu un peu
tendue et vous vous êtes aussi des élus
locaux comme ici le maire adjoint un peu
les choses l'assemblée là
c'est le sentiment que ça donne en fait
on voit même des députés de l'opposition
qui sont prennent directement au
ministre de façon très violente
de respect de notre système républicain
de notre de nos institutions qui
semble plus flagrant aujourd'hui que
dans les précédentes mandatures
c'est pas de l'énervement c'est pas de
l'exaspération c'est un peu de lassitude
ils entendent beaucoup de bruit beaucoup
de bruit beaucoup de spectacles
politiciens et ils entendent très peu
d'actions politiques ils disent
c'est n'importe quoi
ils disent c'est honteux de ce qu'on
portait comme ça ils sont assez
critiques en fait en septembre une
petite anecdote je visitais pour la
rentrée des classes une école de CM2 et
un moment il y a un gamin qui lève le
doigt qui venait monsieur le député je
peux vous poser une question alors je
dis bah évidemment oui il me dit vous
savez il m'arrive de regarder la
télévision avec mes parents et on voit
ce que vous faites dans l'hémicycle et
mes parents me disent ah là c'est
toujours le foutoir et j'étais bien
obligé de reconnaître que l'expression
n'était pas très agréable mais qu'elle
n'était pas totalement infondée vous
avez une partie de la population qui
aujourd'hui
va se positionner en opposition à cette
théâtralisation parce que tout bêtement
les habitudes de vote la perception de
la politique va faire que la politique
est quelque chose de sérieux vous
trouvez ça notamment dans l'électorat AG
dans une partie de l'électorat centriste
les débats enflammés en hémicycle et sur
les écrans sont les parties les plus
visibles et les plus commentées du
travail parlementaire
mais derrière cette façade la nouvelle
Assemblée fonctionne et légifère en un
mot elle fait son travail si jamais des
Français sont désespérés du niveau des
débats en séance ils peuvent regarder
les débats en commission ils peuvent
lire les rapports parlementaires et ils
diront que il y a du travail qui est
fait et que et bien le théâtre a son
importance s'il charrie des choses en
termes de représentativité etc il faut
pas le mépriser c'était théâtre il a
toute son importance mais que ça
n'exclut pas le fait que il y a du
travail de fond et que ce travail il
continue nécessairement être mené il
n'est pas de moins bonne qualité qu'hier
il est simplement moins visible on se
rend pas compte parce que tout ça est un
petit peu masqué obstrué si vous voulez
par ces jeux de posture donc les députés
à mon sens doivent faire très attention
à ne pas tomber dans cette caricature
[Applaudissements]
quelle hérite ou qu'elle séduisent cette
nouvelle Assemblée ne laisse pas les
Français indifférents
la nouvelle série parlementaire qui
s'est ouverte en juin 2022 n'en est qu'à
sa première saison
[Musique]
à elle de surprendre et d'évoluer pour
ne jamais lasser son auditoire
[Musique]